the 50 names on this list are of people
suspected of being guards at the
Auschwitz concentration camp none of
them have ever been tried but the
official german agency hunting nazi
fugitives wants to change that in the
eyes of chief investigator court slim
it's never too late to bring Nancy
criminals to justice for me but only for
me personally it is still meaningful
these people might be old but they were
involved in something that was unique in
modern times uniquely brutal uniquely
criminal you can't tell the victims the
survivors that we're not interested in
this issue anymore just because the men
are old and these events happen 70 years
ago in Demon's isleton on CPR through
society for girls in Auschwitz a name
that will be forever remembered in
infamy home to the largest extermination
camp in the Nazi Empire wherever a
million men women and children were
murdered between 1942 and 1945
the Frankfurt outfits trials in the
1960s saw just 21 former camp staff
jailed the majority of the guards
responsible never faced justice men
sakta for your eye no sale they used to
say that guards could only be found
complicit if they were involved in an
act that caused the death of an inmate
Tim told NSF dings fielder for example
the inmate who was taken to the gas
chamber by the accused guard especially
in digas como filled water well then
there's the guard the most glaring case
who turned on the gas town as God's Indy
guards come on I enlighted it or the
iron fielder shrim and his team were
unrelenting in their efforts to
prosecute former concentration camp
guard John damyang yoke a landmark case
the trial was the first time a non
German was charged by Germany with Nazi
war crimes what also distinguished the
case was the accused being convicted
without evidence of any concrete action
the court in Munich judged damn young
Luke to have been a guard at the suburb
or death camp in occupied Poland he was
found guilty on 28,000 counts of
accessory to murder the Ukrainian was
sentenced to five years in jail but died
in March 2012 before his appeal had been
heard and the verdict could not be
confirmed by Germany's Supreme Court
which shrim and his fellow Nazi hunters
see the initial court ruling as
sufficient confirmation they are now
planning to prosecute 50 a schvitz
guards s Knut ed and lil any action that
supported this factory of death is
enough felt all day they can we debate
let's take another example Dale
wholesale a guard home and watch tower
and prevented a prisoner from escaping
is complicit if the prisoner had been
able to escape he wouldn't have been
killed nika to develop inin could boot
man is glad to see that the culprits are
still being brought
justice he was among the joint
plaintiffs in the damn yaniel trial
gutman whose mother and brother were
murdered in the suburb or concentration
camp was in the courtroom when damien
rock was sentenced further prosecutions
of camp guards he says are important for
the survivors and the families of
victims this week to look cool does not
allow it means satisfaction to see
something being done to me to see the
dead or not forgotten a fee to see
people hunting the perpetrators even
when they're extremely old Roy Wood out
our into his court bootman traveled from
Berlin to Munich several times to attend
the dimion York trial what made it all
the more testing for him was the
defendants refusal to testify delicious
finished life of course it isn't easy to
see one of the people responsible for
murdering my mother and brother who
torment us Buddhist fought for loosened
preferred to knock knee eamon he was the
first person I ever saw who was directly
responsible for any knobs rude the
indifference he showed was deeply
upsetting for me to do you shouldn't it
is because of people like quote Gutman
that could shrim and his team continue
to scour the archives even now 70 years
after the nazi regime they are busy
preparing new cases and had not daunted
by the odds against them there was
Morgan's of ensign the OC to be honest
about it the chances of a guilty
sentence are certainly not very great
these people are around 90 years old now
that age an individual can suddenly
become unfit to face trial or die before
the ruling of the 50 people we're now
investigating many will not live to be
sentenced
neat so fulfilled in couch trim will be
forwarding the 50 names on this list to
prosecutors the charge is accessory to
murder a crime for which no statute of
limitations applies no matter how many
decades later